okay cool let's get started so
uh
uh okay it's kind of complicated right
like a it's kind of amazing right like
this technology is so Advanced so that
you can do all of these things together
but uh I still have to do them one by
one like I have like 10 action items
maybe more than 10. I need to also
connects with Wi-Fi that's uh that's
actually something I have to do
um okay so but oh let's let's get
started oh I need to have my notes
so what we're going to do today is that
we're going to continue with the
asymptotics last time a little bit for
like a about like 15 to 20 minutes
um this is just to wrap up what we have
discussed
um and as I said this uh first lecture
is always kind of like a little bit
tricky to for me to teach it because
um the tools there you know if you want
to make it formal it requires some kind
of backgrounds
um and if you don't want to make it
formal sometimes there is a little bit
confusion so
um from from the this lecture the second
half of this lecture I think we are
going to talk about
um things that require less background
in some sense
um and it's more self-content
okay so the plan is that asymptotics
and then um the so-called uniform
convergence
I'll Define what it is
and uniform convergence will be the main
focus for the first few weeks of the
lecture
okay so let's start by reviewing what we
have done last time so what we have the
last time was this theorem where we
showed that
um
um if you assume
consistency
which is something that is kind of like
we basically just assume without much
justification you know
um it's not always true and it also
depends on the problem
uh the consistency basically means that
set a hat will converge to Theta star we
call that hat is the ERM the empirical
risk minimizer and Theta star is the
minimizer of the population risk so you
care about recovering through the star
or recovering something as good as the
star
and we also assume a bunch of other
things like for example The Hyphen is
full rank
and also some regulatory conditions
which I didn't even Define
um exactly for example this requires
something like some of the virus
it's financed so you can apply the
serums and then under this assumptions
we have that
actually it's kind of challenging for me
because this
Podium after I read it it becomes
unstable
it's kind of like I feel like I'm
writing where I'm on a boat
um
but it's probably good for me to
practice
my kind of like what is this called like
I would be better with some of the
sports I guess after you do this anyway
okay so uh so I guess we have discussed
that you know that's the distribution
you know the order of the difference
between Cedar height and sales star the
order is on the order of one over square
root n and formally write it like this
you scale backwards in and you know that
it's on the other four
and you also know something about the
laws
you know that the excess risk L to the
Hat minus l0 star is on the on the order
of one over
n and if you formally write it you are
going to scale by n and then you say
it's on all the constants and also you
know that the distribution of theta hat
minus the star this is converging to a
gaussian distribution which means zero
and some covariance and this covariance
is kind of complicated but let me write
it
um something like this
this is just reviewing what we have
written last time
and four we also know the the
distribution of
the excess risk this is a distribution
of a scalar because the accessories is a
scalar it will scale it by n then you
know the distribution is converging to
the distribution of this random variable
and this random variable as is a
gaussian random variable with covariance
means zero and covariance something like
above but not exactly
you don't have to remember exactly what
the covariance here is because you know
I don't even remember them
um if I don't read my notes
these are you know there are some
intuitions about this which I'm going to
discuss but generally this is just uh
was something you got from derivations
so so last time we have kind of like
roughly justify the number one number
two and today I'm going to again give a
relatively heuristic approve for three
and four just very quick so that we can
wrap up this
um
um so I guess just to very quickly
review what we have done last time so
the key idea to kind of like derive all
of this is by
um doing internal expansion internal
expansion I think the key equation let
me just rewrite it what we have done
last time is this
so you look at the Taylor hat the
gradient of the empirical loss I see the
Hat this is guaranteed to be zero
because set a half is the minimizer of
the empirical loss and you try to expand
this around to the star
and you get something like this
plus high order terms
and then you
um rearrange this and get set a height
minus Theta star is equal to
the inverse of the empirical housing
um xcsr times
Theta hat plus high order terms
and then you say that I'm going to
replace all the hats by L like I'll hide
by L using uh some kind of a lot of
large numbers or uniform convergence and
last time we have roughly discussed that
this is on order form of script and
because you have a concentration this is
the average of this is roughly on all
the form scoring plus number L Theta
sorry this is Theta star
which is roughly on the other one square
root n and and this one is converting to
a constant so that's why the whole thing
is converging to something on order form
of scripture and this time we are going
to make a little bit more formal
so so we've got the exact distribution
of the high metal set of stuff I'll be
I'll make this part really quick just to
so that um you know if you are not
familiar with the background you don't
get confused too much
um so
um so the idea is that so if you look at
what what's the distribution of this if
you think about this this is the product
of two random variables and you roughly
know what the solution of each of the
random variable is right so this one is
going to converts to a constant which is
it's going to converge to another
IO Theta star inverse and this one is
going to be a gaussian distribution if
you scale it correctly right so and and
basically what you need to know is that
what's the product what's the the
product of these two random variables
what's the distribution of the product
of two random variables when you know uh
each of them what happens with each of
them and what happens is formally what
you know what you do is your first scale
best version so that each of these two
random variables are on order of one so
that you can reason about them uh easily
so you scale by one word by squared and
you get this
and then you have
inverse and now you scale this empirical
green by square rooting and also you get
square root n and also let's fill in
the population gradient which is zero so
this one is zero I just write it here to
make it closer to something you know
um and then this plus high order terms
um this is still hello terms even your
multiplied by square root only because I
think there's a typo in the direction of
something pointed out which is really
nice but still you know imagine how you
multiply it still has all the terms
compared to the other terms right so
and now this one
let's call them that's called Z this and
Z by law of large number all I think by
Central limit theorem Z is a gaussian
discussion because
um and with some covariance and what's
the covariance the covariance will be
um
the covariance of nebula
IO
okay
X Y Theta
why this is just because what is L hats
Theta star minus
this
is really just a um
this is the empirical version of the the
right hand side the the the population
gradient so this is really some one over
n times sum of number l x i y i
Theta star minus expectation of this way
of the same thing maybe you can
for Simplicity let's just write X Y here
let's start
right so you apply this you apply
Central limit theorem you know that if
you scale this by square root in then
you get a gaussian distribution
right so so that's why we know the
random variable Z has gaussian
distribution and we know this one will
converge to a constant as n goes to
Infinity
and
um there is a theorem that specifically
deal with this but actually you know if
you think about it this makes a lot of
sense so if you want to know the what's
the left hand side basically it just
becomes the distribution of the right
hand side it's a constant times a
gaussian disclose okay so this constant
times the gaussian distribution so
basically we have to figure out what's
this what's the distribution
um here it's like what what is the
distribution of a constant times Z
so
um
so basically abstractly speaking what we
are dealing with here is that
so the question we're dealing here with
here is that
just
so different color for abstraction so
basically you are asking what is the
distribution of a times Z
if a is a constant
and Z is from from some gaussian
distribution with covalent Sigma
right so and
I'm missing this page
and you know that there's a Lemma which
says that
if in under this case
A and Z also is also gaussian
distribution with covariance which means
zero and covariance a sigma a transpose
I think this is a homework question
homework zero question I'm not sure
whether it's still there I I forgot to
double check
um but um
this is something you can do like a
what's the transformation of a gaussian
distribution still transfer still a
gaussian distribution it's just the
covariance got transformed and actually
the way to transform the covariance is
that you like to multiply the
transformation and right multiply the
transpose of it you get the new covers
so so this is something you know it's
not that cheaper to to derive this but
this is something
um you can either look up from a book or
you can derive it yourself
right so with this a small Lemma then we
know that the distribution
um
okay star converges to replace the
converges to um
a gaussian distribution which means zero
where a so here a corresponds to
the nubla IL Theta Star right
and and sigma corresponds to
Sigma corresponds to this one and you
just plug in uh these two choices then
foreign
we got
number IO
plus Square L for the star minus 1 times
covariance
of WL x y 0 star times WL star Wars
okay
um this is Convergence in distribution
any questions so far
I realized that my camera is frozen I
don't know why
something seems to be wrong
for those people who are in a zoom
meeting you'll see my video
it's kind of Frozen
I see thanks maybe let me read turn it
off and then turn it down
okay sounds working now
okay cool and you can see that height
you can see everything now okay thanks
okay cool
um any questions also if you're on a
zoom meeting also feel free to just
unmute and ask any questions
this is inverse yeah
so which term you are which term am I
asking this one
foreign
yes it's exactly the same one it's
supposed to be the same thing transports
right but this is a symmetric Matrix so
the transpose is the same itself so this
is -1
okay so I guess um what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to skip the proof for the the
derivation for the number four
um it's kind of like the same thing it's
just that you have to
kind of like because you already know
the distribution of data hat you should
know the distribution of theta hat and
what you do is you do some tell
expansion to make it a polynomial of set
a hat and then you can use the what you
know about header hat um all of these in
electronics I guess I'm going to skip
this part
for example
is the reason for that
you mean the covarence seems the other
like the new yeah
[Music]
um I think there's a connection but um
but I don't feel like a
it's you know I think all like this has
since shows up very often in many
different cases right so there is some
connection but I don't feel like it has
to be like it's not like it super
closely related so that it's important
enough to know yeah
um
yeah okay so I guess I'll skip the proof
for number four um if you're interested
you can look at the proof in Electro
notes
um and what I'm gonna do is that I'm
going to spend another five minutes to
talk about
um
a correlate a corollary of this theorem
which is in a more
um
maybe a more
typical setting like here here this
theorem is very general because it
doesn't say anything about the loss
function it doesn't say anything about
the model it works for almost everything
as long as you have the consistency and
here let me especially instantiate this
theorem for the so-called well-specified
case where you use log likelihood and
then we can see the the all of these
covariance becomes a little bit of like
more intuitive and and things becomes a
little bit easier
um
so this is the so-called wild specified
case
so um I guess in addition
to serum one
let's also assume that let's suppose
there exists some
probabilistic model
parametrized by Theta
so such the Y is given X and Theta so so
you assume that Y is generated from this
uh probabilistic model
right so so so what does it mean so
basically means so let's say Suppose
there exists a set of star I'm using the
super the subscript here to
differentiate to differentiate from the
Theta star uh defined before which was
the minimizer of the population risk and
actually they are the same but for now
they are the difference so you so
basically you assume that the existence
is a star such that the y i the data is
generated from
conditional exercise is generated from
this probabilistic model
right so so you assume so this is well
this is why it's called well specified
it means that your data is generated
from some problem State model
and also in this case suppose you use
the log the loss function is the log
likelihood
right before we didn't really say what
the loss function needs to be right it
could be anything and now let's say the
log from the loss function is the log
likelihood of this probabilistic model
think of this as for example logistic
regression right
um
our linear regression with gaussian
noise so so your log likelihood could be
cross entropy laws could be like mean
Square laws depending on what the
probabilistic model uh you have
right so this is your loss function and
when you do this then uh you know a
bunch of things which are nicer in some
sense so first of all you know that the
Theta star is equals to
the Theta sub Star right so recall that
this is the minimizer of the population
loss and this is the ground shoes this
is the one that generates our data and
and in this case you can prove that when
you have infinite data where Theta star
is the minimizer of the infinite data
case you can uh recover the ground to
say a sub star so they are exactly the
same thing
and uh you also know uh a bunch of
signals other things for example you
know that
the the gradient
this is kind of trivial I'm just writing
it here because it used to be that I
need to use prove this in a proof but if
you don't care about the proof this is
just an inconvenience step that you know
so you know that expected gradient over
the population
H Theta star is zero
and also you know
what's the covariance
of the gradient
this is the covariance of the gradient
is the quantity that we care about right
because you know in the previous
theorem the covariance of the gradient
shows up in the variance of the optical
hatchimal signal star the covariance of
the gradient
is
icsr
I guess from now on we don't distinguish
set of superstars say the superscript
star and see the subscript star because
they are the same
and you know the covariance actually
happens to be the hessing
and with the covariance of the gradient
happens to be the hessing then the
covariance of cell height Manifesto star
can be simplified
so this
recall that this used to be a gaussian
distribution which cope with something
like
that's right the covariance of the
silica benefits is used with this
product of three things three matrices
but now what's in the middle is the same
as the hashing that's what we claimed in
number three so that means that you can
cancel
uh this from with this and you get only
one term
so what what's left is that just the
inverse of the hazard
maybe I should just use black fiber
um
yeah and you also know uh if you plug in
you know like this the covariance of the
the gradients you basically plug in
three into all the statements that you
had before then you can also get
something like for example one of the
important thing is this
the
excess risk
I guess we have claimed that it's on
auto Theta star but actually here you
can be more precise you know that this
is converging to
um basically a half times chi-square
distribution of
um with degree P so p is a dimension
of theta
so suppose you have P parameters then
this is uh
um the distribution of the excess risk
and if you take the expectation of this
so that you get when you look at all the
randomness then what you get is that
expectation of n times excess risk
is equals to the expectation of the
the chi-square distribution
um that this is equals to a half times P
by the way Chi Square distribution if
you you don't have to know anything
detailed about it this is basically the
um the distribution of a sum of P normal
on gaussian Square
um so so you know a lot of things about
it like you know it's a it's positive
and you know that it means like if the
customer with repeat that means
um P you know if you need to know more
about this just Wikipedia uh it's very
easy we don't need anything deep about
it so so the important thing is the the
last equation so basically we know that
the excess risk in expectation here the
expectation is over the randomness of
the data set
right so the accessories if you don't
scale scale by the star sorry if you
don't scale it by and then you get this
is equals to
I guess I should write conversion to
because it wouldn't be exactly equal
this is a half times p over n
so basically you don't even get the
dependency on N but you also get a
dependency on P so another dimension so
you know that
um
um the
worst order of excess risk of course
there's a high order terms middle of one
over
and actually you know the variance of
excess risk which I don't think is super
important the virus is smaller than me
okay so in electron notes I think we
have proofs for all of this
um but I think I'm not going to discuss
the proof the main the most important
thing I think is
this one
and and this one
you know so the number the the first
thing is saying that
the cover the the shape of the Hackman
SSR the randomness you is
uh the shape is kind of like the same as
the inverse of the Hashim so so in those
directions where your head is you know
steeper
then you have less stochasticity
right so and in those directions where
the heads is smaller then you have more
stochasticity
um and the the last one is saying that
it doesn't matter what hessing is the
only thing that matters is the number of
parameters if you care about this kind
of like asymptotic regime
um the only thing that matters is the
parameter P
um the number of parameters
we're going to discuss the limitation of
all of the theorems in a moment but
that's this this is what we got from
this asymptotic approach
any questions so far
Okay cool so I guess uh let's uh if you
are interested in more details you can
take a look at the lecture notes
um so I guess now let's move on to uh uh
uniform convergence uh and
um in often people call this kind of
line of research called uh knowledge
methodic
so let's first discuss that this is
actually the
um the kind of like the the approach
we're going to take for the rest of the
lecture we're gonna care about knowing
asymptotics instead of asymptotic bonds
so the reason so let me Define uh let me
motivate what you know what Define what
it is and and motivate why we care about
it so recall that when you have
asymptotic bonds just a
that's like what I wrote about you know
that this else has L7 Stars the final
outcome is something like this is equals
to P over 2 and
plus little point over
eight of blade of Y over n
however the problem is that here you are
hiding
a lot of things in this little little
one little one over n so you hide
all dependencies
other than the dependencies on other
than
so what does it mean so in this rate of
later all notation you also have
dependency on P so so if you tell me
it's important regime you get this Bond
what happens is that you could either
have p over 2N plus one over n Square
maybe the real weight is this
it could also happen that the real word
could be this
so both of these two cases would be a
possible situation if you tell me the
bound above right I wouldn't have ways
to distinguish this because
the
right like this one is hidden in this
little little notation because the
lateral notation doesn't care about any
dependencies or anything else it only
clears for these dependencies on love
and at least in the context of
asymptotics
so so this is the the problem because
clearly if your rate is on the right
hand it's something on the right hand
side then this is very bad rate
right very bad by the way by the way I
mean the how
how does this depend on how
I guess maybe that's just quite bomb
right so suppose your bond is on the
right hand side then it's a very bad
Bond because uh this requires uh n to be
bigger than P to the 50 so that
this bond is smaller than what
right because you need a second term to
be smaller than one then you need n to
be bigger than P to the 50.
[Music]
yes yes
so exactly
um so
um okay I'm going back to this so um so
the bound on the right hand side is
going to be very bad and the back the
the bone on the the left hand side this
one is kind of pretty good in some sense
right
but you have no ways to distinguish them
because these two things would be
connected towards p over 2 and plus
little y Over N in the in the asymptotic
cells so
um so that's the that's the biggest
problem
and
and also in some sense
when you have other dependencies on the
for example the dimensionality even the
dependencies on N is not the only thing
that matters for example another kind of
like a more extreme situation is that
supposed to compare
p over square root n versus p over 2N
Plus
this
but I suppose you have suppose you know
you have two of these bounds and if you
use asymptotics right if you write in
the asymptotic way then you are going to
conclude that this is p over 2 N plus
negative 1 over RN in the asymptotic
language and this one will be something
like P over square root and plus little
while over square rooted so it sounds
like this is bad because this one has
high order dependencies on on N right
it's indeed too when n goes to Infinity
the right hand side is smaller than the
left hand side
but if you think about the more moderate
regime of n then it's not really true
because
for for the bond to be less than one
right so if you want p over square root
n to be less than one this means that n
is bigger than P Square
but if you want this p over 2 plus P of
100
and square to be less than one this
means Chinese needs to be at least
equals larger than
um P to the 50 right so
so so when n goes to Infinity then the
the left-hand side you know uh it's
worse it's the worst bone but in most of
the cases the left hand side is actually
a better box so if you want P to the
left hand side to be a better Bond on
the right than the right hand side
I can see if you solve this
maybe you can even ignore this the
um if you solve this this is kind of
roughly saying that and if n is smaller
than I think I did this calculation at
some point and it's smaller into the
P to the 66 then
actually the bone on the left hand side
is better than bone on the right hand
side just because there's P to the 100
is too big right so so basically the
comparison
um basically if you use this asymptotic
language things becomes a little weird
if you consider other dependencies on on
other parameters for example if you have
a dependency on the dimension a
dimension for machine learning for
modern machine learning is very high so
so this is why I think asymptotics even
though they are very powerful they don't
necessarily always apply to the modern
machine learning just because it has the
dependency
um uh or for other terms right in in the
in the high order case right so like
this one has
like
this one has
this one has the dependency on P so
that's the that's the main issue
basically
okay so so what we do
um uh how do we fix this right the first
thing we need to do is to fix the
language in some sense we need to
um not only consider and goes to
Infinity we have to also consider other
quantities uh in this world so
so basically what non-exymptotic does is
that
you care about this is just a
um a term or kind of like a pro
approach this is basically saying that
you you only had
absolute constant
in your bond
you have to hide something because you
know if you have to care about every
constant it's going to be too
complicated for Theory right it's going
to be a lot of calculations but uh here
we allow us to hide absolute content but
we cannot hide any other dependencies or
any other things
so uh so you're not allowed to have
dependency on P when n goes to Infinity
so and my absolute constant this really
means that this is a universal concept
something like three five something you
can replace by
a real numerical number
um so
um and actually to kind of like uh make
everything easier so we are going to
introduce this notation
um big old notation
this is actually sometimes this big old
notation has a little bit um different
interpretation so I'm going to
I'm not I wouldn't say I I'm really
defining it but I'm going to just be
clear about what the big old notation uh
means from now so now big old notations
from now on only highest Universal
constant and and let me have actually a
kind of like more technical definition
which is actually useful in some cases
when you really do a lot of theory
sometimes
I'm not sure whether some of you have
this confusion about whether you should
use Big O or Omega
Omega like the big Omega like sometimes
it could be confused confusing so let me
Define what this speaker really means it
really means that so every occurrence
at least this is what means in this
course it may not be exactly always the
same for every paper but I think people
are converging to this kind of
interpretation so every occurrence of
big of x
is
a placeholder
for some function
as a f x
such that
uh for every X in r
f x is less than CX
for some
absolute
constant
C
bigger than zero
so basically this is saying that if you
replace so maybe more explicitly
is saying that you can replace
our current
replace all of x
by effects such that
the statement is true
so
um
so basically if you see a statement with
a lot of O of X or something right it
means that you can replace all of these
occurrences of big old notations by some
thing more explicit such that the
statement is still true
so it may seem to be over Q as a
definition of Big O you know which you
probably already familiar with but in
some cases you know at least I've I've
seen so many cases where I got confused
I have to kind of really literally
verify whether this I satisfy this
definition
um anyway okay so and also just for for
notational kind of convenience sometimes
we also write a is less than b this is
just equivalent to
um there exists the absolute constant
C larger than zero such that
a is less than c times B and and
technically if you really wants to be
kind of like very solid this statement
should only apply to positive A and B
positive and because for negative ones
you have to
you you probably you know ideally you
should just write this only for positive
Envy that's my that's my suggestion
because for negative ones it just
becomes a little bit confusing
um
so so the point here is that there's no
like when you define this big old thing
right so it depends on the literature
sometimes when people Define Big O they
have to Define some limit but here in
this course you know the Big O just
really means this there's no limit
taking you don't have to think about any
limit
could be functions or other more complex
qualities
Okay cool so these are just some
notations to
okay so now
the kind of the bond that we're care
about is that
so so
we are interested in
in this notation we are interested in
bonds
of the form
like the excess risk
so I'll
touch Ubuntu accessory I will say the
height minus L see the star
by
something like
Big O of some function of maybe p and n
where P could be a dimension and N could
be the
um the number of data points of course
you can replace this by a function of
other things but the point here is that
after you write this there's nothing
else hidden in a big or only a universal
constant
and this will you know once you have
this kind of language you can compare
things you know in a more proper way
and in the next few lectures our goal is
to basically show how to provide bounds
of this kind of form
sometimes the bond could be more
complicated not only depending on the
parameters number of parameters and
number of data points it could depend on
the norm of the parameters so and so
forth
um the point is that we always only had
Universal constants
okay any questions
uh for some yes that's very important
because if you replace it for all
because here there's also
like
[Music]
um
no I think it's for some so you
literally only need existence of one
function that says by this such that if
you replace that if you replace your
statement by f of x the statement is
true so yeah I think this is actually
very good question because I got
confused by this many times so maybe
let's let's uh let's give an example
right so you say the excess risk
is less than or one over square rooted
what does this mean this means that you
can replace this this is your iPhone
right you can replace this by for
example five over square root and such
that this is exactly true
but you don't need to say that for every
iPhone so if you say for every F then it
means that if you if you place by 0.1
over scoring it still has to be true
right that's too much right you only
need existence of one
but of course you know if you have
existed one five then there's always
there's always other F which which is
bigger that can also be replaced but you
only need one well
and also actually maybe this is a little
bit Advanced but some this this kind of
like interpretation also allows you to
have
be all in your condition even for
example you can this is a this could be
a lot of advice but for example you can
write for all
like when
if n is bigger than o p
then
uh
excess risk
is less than one
this is you know I'm not saying this is
a correct statement but this statement
would be interpreted as if you replace
this o of P by 2p then it's going to be
correct or if you replace this op by
some
function some constant times P it's
going to be a correct statement and it's
not omega here it's a it's really big O
which is uh sometimes confusing
okay cool so now let's move on to
um uh the the key idea that we are going
to have right so so to bound this access
rates how do we achieve bound like this
the key idea is to
to somehow say that El High Theta is
close to L Theta right in some way in
some sense this is a
um I need to specify what I really mean
by these two functions are closed right
are they closed at every theater or are
they closed at a specific setup so here
is a small claim which
you know tells you what you really need
so what you need is that so suppose
I always say the star
is close to IO official star
suppose these two loss functions
empirical and population loss are closed
actually a star
and also suppose
they are closed
I say the Hat
and here actually only one set closeness
so
so suppose you'll have both of this then
this implies that
i o Theta hat minus L Theta star
is less than two alpha
so basically you just need to show that
this two loss function the empirical
loss and population loss are closed I
still star and I Theta hat
then you can get along the excess tricks
by two times Alpha and the proof is
actually very simple
um what you do is that you know that
this is compartment Theta hack but
consider stock right and your condition
involves compartment L versus L hat so
you have to do kind of flexible
arrangement to kind of predict them
right so what you do is you say
I want to compare
this too and I write this as a sum of
three terms
I will say the height minus
L Heights you first
compare this L of theta Hat by L height
of theta hat and then you have Al Hazard
effect you compare this with L find the
star
and then you compare as health to the
star
by with L7
anyway let me I don't know why the video
is freezer at the end
let me restart it
okay and the reason why this should be
free Okay
um
so
so why you want to do these three things
right it's kind of you know once you see
it it's kind of obvious because this one
is the condition one of the condition
right
this one is
this the second condition
and this one
is the the first condition
and you also have this one which
compared directly to the height and say
the star but this is comparing them at L
hat and you know that L has this hat
minus L High single star is less than
zero because Theta hat is the minimizer
of L hat so this term is less than zero
and
this term is less less than Alpha this
term is just an alpha so in total you
get
if you continue you get too Alpha
okay
so basically this is saying that it
suffices to show the two conditions
the first condition is that L hat and L
is closed ICL star the second condition
is that L height and L are closed at
so it turns out that the kind of the the
challenge to prove these two
inequalities are like the difficulty are
completely different
so let's say if this is number one this
is number two number one is much very
very easy to prove and number two will
require you know a lot of work which
takes a few weeks
um
maybe not a few weeks like two weeks
um there's
um it's just a
the only reason is that you know
um like of course if you put absolute
value here it's still true right and
actually you can also Bond absolute
value if you want uh the only reason is
that if you don't have the absolute
value the
so so this set conditions are satisfied
it's a little bit easier slightly easier
you you need you need one fewer step
that's why
um in most of the books you don't have
that step and also you save a constant a
factor of two so so you know in my
actually this is a very good question in
my first time that teaches I I just have
absolute value and then later in the
lecture I have to do additional steps to
fix that constant which makes a little
bit like a little bit annoying yeah
but fundamentally you are right there's
no real difference
yeah which I'm going to show the first
thing called very just right now the
first inner call is very easy
um and I'll I'll tell you why they are
different it sounds like they are very
similar right so the difference is that
um I guess let me see whether it's ready
for me to talk about a difference
um
maybe let me not talk about the
difference first I mean first to show
the inequality one and see what why it's
relatively easy
and so to do that
um so so the goal is to show one
and
the main tool we're going to use is the
so-called concentration inequality
so
um and this is in some sense a a
non-essymatotic version
of the law of large number
so it's trying to prove the same kind of
things but in a different language and
with a stronger form
um so this is not a some conversion
I guess of central limit theorem
um and now you don't have and you don't
have to to deal with the limit you just
have a bound that depends on it
and I think probably some of you have
heard of this inequality called often
inequality
I think this thing probably is going to
be it's taught in well nine cs109
or some of the statistics class but
anyway you don't have to know um HP4
um as a prerequisite and let me Define
the inequality so this is trying to deal
with a sum of independent random
variables so let's say X1 up to x n
be independent
random variables
and suppose
they are bonded
um each of them is bounded by a and b i
you can think of A and B are just
constant maybe zero and one
um
um and almost surely for every eye
um and
so we care about the the mean
so the mean of this random variable is
defined to be x i and sorry it's defined
to be mu
and so the the central question is how
different
is the empirical mean from the popular
the the average from the from the the
expectation right so care about how
small is this
and this is a random variable so you
have to have a probabilistic statement
so the claim is that the probability
that this
difference is small
is very big
alternatively you can say that the
probability that this difference is big
is very small
um they're just the same
um so you get how big it is it's very
close to one and the difference from one
is this exponentially small number and
what's in the exponential is something
like this
beautiful
okay so this is the formal statement
maybe let me try to interpret it a
little bit and by instantiating a
special case so
uh if you define a sigma Square to be 1
over n times sum of b i minus a i
square right from 1 to 1.
so then the sigma
can be viewed
as kind of the virus
of one over sum of x i you know this is
not an executive variance right because
but it's kind of like a some kind of
like a upper Bond of the violence why
because if you look at the virus over in
times the sum of x i
you know that the variance is linear so
um so first of all you get 1 over n
Square in front because the variance is
quadratic in scaling and then you have
the in your relatives you have the sum
of the variance of x i
and then this is equals to one over n
Square
by definition x i minus expectation x i
square and now because each of each of
these x i x i is always between b and a
I right so x i is between BR and a i
and expectation of x i you know as a
consequence also is between BR and a i
that means that this thing the the this
thing is
uh smaller than
um
bi minus a i because both of these two
quantities are in this interval so the
difference of them is also uh smaller
than b and a i you get b i s square or
each of these terms so so that's why the
the total the whole thing
uh maybe I guess also including a while
running Square so the whole thing
is smaller than one over n Square Times
sum of bi minus a i square right from
one to it
[Music]
um
let me see why I'm missing her
I think I have a
I think I have a
type of Heap
okay so so basically you can think of
each of this
um
p and AI square is the variance and then
they will take the sum of them and you
divide by 1 square that's kind of the
yeah the variance of the the whole
exercise and and suppose you take this
View and you can see what is this is
saying what this inner chord is saying
is the following so if you take Epsilon
to be
square root some constant c times Sigma
Square Times log n
so this is something like a constant o
of Sigma square root logon so you take
Epsilon to be something a little bit
bigger than the variance
um by by squaring login then you know
that you plug this option into the whole
thing inequality
and where C is a large constant
then you plug in this to the uh for
example C is larger than 10 and if you
plug in this Epsilon to the fourth
inequality what you got is that
so
probability one over n times sum of x i
minus mu
this is actually the most interesting
regime of this inequality when you plug
in Epson to be on this level that's the
typically when you use it you always use
absence with this level because this is
the the useful regime so when you apply
it you get this is less than all of
Sigma login
because I press this by Epson is bigger
than 1 minus two times exponential now
let's plug in epsilon so uh so you guys
this is to
maybe let's first not replace that
iPhone let's first replace Sigma versus
it you can see that's the the right hand
side by my definition of Sigma square
right so this is the same as the whole
inequality and then plugging up Zone I
get one minus two exponential
uh
to login
to two times bigger
I guess 2 is also in the Big O so you
got
right so and now you choose this big O
to be a large constant right so recall
that
um like like the speaker is you can
replace this figure by a large constant
right so so then you got this to be
something like
1 minus
maybe let's say
I guess maybe it's here it's easier to
if I just keep the C
especially I get 2C here
this is
C
then you got n to the minus 2C 2 times n
to the minus two c and if you pick this
constant C to be something like 10 then
you get 1 minus
2 to the N minus 20 right so so so
basically this is saying that um you
have a very very high probability such
that the difference is smaller than
Sigma log 1. so in other words with high
probability
so with probability let's say larger
than one minus n to the minus 10. you
have that
the mean
is the empirical mean is
close to the expectation in the sense
that they are closed in
uh
in this sense right they are they're
bounded the difference between them are
bounded by Big O of Sigma times logic
so so basically this is saying that if
you think of Sigma as the as the
variance as the cold code variance then
you cannot be you it's very hard for you
to try to deviate from the mean
um by something larger much larger than
the virus right so you you this is the
deviation from the mean and this is the
variance up to Times Square Root login
often log factor in this course is not
very important so this thing you cannot
deviate from the the mean by a large
Factor uh uh of the of the variable of
course this variance is not a real virus
it's the this is perceived virus you
actually we're gonna get back to this
concept this is sometimes called there's
a concept called um variance proxy so
which we're going to talk more about it
so
so in some sense it's kind of like if
you draw this it's kind of like you are
saying that this random variable
this
suppose you call this x height a random
variable if you look at the distribution
of this random variable is something
like this
and and the mean is Mu right suppose
this is the meal and you look at
something
deviate from the mule by Sigma Square
login
and then you are saying that the math in
this part is extremely small how small
they are they are smaller than inverse
polynomial of any right so the mass here
is smaller than into the minus 2C or
maybe inverse probably in
so and you can see that this Bond cannot
be much much smaller
so and and the wealthiest way to see it
is that if this is really a sigma it's
really the standard deviation then your
bond cannot be improved much right
because
for any random variable
for any run bar we always have some
probability
so the bones
cannot
be improved
much
of course this this is a somehow kind of
like a just intuition right because if I
need to Define what they mean by not
improve much but intuitively this Pawn
shouldn't be able to improve the match
because for any random variable
you always have some Mass they're always
some nice
Within
I mean plus minus 10 deviation right so
if you really kind of
kind of look at the interval
um
uh defined by the standard deviation
there's always some nice Index right
there's an actual constant one might see
that so you cannot say that
so you cannot kind of like make this
intervals much much smaller and get the
same bound because you know if you get
me too too small then you have a lot of
mass in it
So Okay cool so now let's interpret this
a little more so let's say we take a and
we instantiate even more so let's take a
to be on out of
maybe -1
it's a negative number and B is on all
of one right so this is typically the
the important thing right so random
variable is between minus point one
maybe minus a constant for constant then
what you have is that
the empirical mean minus the
uh expectation is
smaller than big of Sigma Square logar
this is the same thing I have written
and what is Sigma Sigma is
square root one over N squared times the
sum of bi minus a i
score and this is something each of the
bi and ai's on out of one so you get one
over N squared times n because there are
any of these terms so this is one over
square root
so so Sigma is another order of one over
square root and that's the variance of
your
mean estimate uh of the empirical mean
so that's why if you plug in this choice
of two Sigma you get squared and square
root login
so basically you cannot deviate by and
sometimes people write this as
foreign
just to hide all the log factors so if
you don't have
a lot factor is basically saying that
you cannot deviate by more than one over
Square rooting and this is something
um it sounds very abstract for the
moment like uh but uh in the long run
you'll see that this is this kind of
kind of thinking I will be used many
times and it's actually useful to kind
of just burn this in your head if you
really do machine learning theory for
life you know but you don't have to but
for me this is something like
um basically it's like uh you know I
already kind of burned this into my head
in some sense
um any questions
okay so so so this is a kind of a short
kind of like a
um
um a review I'm not sure about how like
I I think probably cs109 doesn't get
into this kind of details but this is
just a kind of a review on the of the
inequality with a lot of kind of like uh
um additional interpretation and now if
you apply often inequality
to our case
let's see what we can get
through the empirical loss
right recall that our goal is to to deal
with this
the difference between this and this
right and this one is one over n times
the sum of
the loss on each of the example
and and this one is really literally the
expectation of the of the sound right
and so this is a perfect case to use hot
inequality because this one corresponds
to x i
and but hopefully requires a bond on a
random variable so we just assume that
in many cases the loss is still bound is
indeed bounded so but here we just we
assume the loss is bounded between one
zero and one you know if the loss is not
bounded you need a little bit more
advanced tools to deal with it but let's
say for now the loss responded between 0
and 1 for example if you use
classification your loss is zero one
loss the loss can only be zero one so
that satisfies this loss
um so for every X and Y and Theta let's
say
then
um if you apply half linear quality what
you get is that
so this is a Lemma but actually it's
really just the application of the
inequality so for any
fixed setup
so suppose you
so so
let's see um
so so our high Theta this is a
basically your sum of X I right
um where x i
is this LXI
Y and Theta
and
so you can compute Sigma square right
you kind of like the
the thick variants that we are thinking
about so the sigma Square I defined was
this the
minus AI Square I from 1 to n and I
guess we have done this well over n
Square Times n which is one over n so
that means that
L has Theta minus L Theta
right is less than
o of
Sigma square root login
with high probability
right so and sigma is
sorry Sigma square is one over n so this
is
o of square root login
and you can also write this as O2 of Y
over squared
so basically for every fixed data the
empirical laws and the population laws
only differ by one over scorpion with
high probability
so
sounds pretty good right so we show that
they are very close and how close they
are they are closed by what um they're
the the difference is one of our
squirting which goes to zero s and goes
to Infinity so it's supposed to be a
small number and there's no other things
hidden here of course you hit a log fact
you hide a lot factor in N but you don't
have any Factor about for example
dimensionality
any questions
so but there is a small issue okay
um
yeah exactly so with high probability
um
so technical I should write the
probability that this
is happening
it's larger than 1 minus n to the O of Y
okay and and and this is actually a good
time to practice this big old notation
basically this is saying that you can
you can replace actually here wait
let me see
I think
should I pick off the line on an Omega
1.
I think I should use Omega fly but maybe
I say C I said there exist a c
uh
such that a constant there exists a
constant not in zeros
such that this is true Maybe
yeah you see that sometimes this is
confusing like no one
um
on the Fly I couldn't figure it out but
but this is what we mean maybe let's say
maybe that's just to say this is 10. I
think I think this is definitely a
correct statement because there is O
here you can hide everything in there so
that's that's what I mean
okay cool
um
okay so so there's a there's this this
is a correct statement but there is a
small uh thing that like there's a
important thing we know we should note
here so what do I mean by for any fixed
data what does this really mean right I
have this title here so this really
means that you you need to first pick
Satan and then you draw after you pick
Theta you jaw
IID
all right x i and y i
from this distribution p
so that these are so that well why you
have to do this because you want to make
sure that I O of x i
y i
Satan
these are independently distributed are
independent
four different eyes so so if you pick
Theta first and then you draw the X I's
then indeed this random variable x i
which is equal to loss are independent
but this doesn't really mean that
you can
you can do this for Theta that depends
on x i which is actually what I'm going
to talk about next so
so
first of all you can apply this for
Theta you can apply this
for Theta is equal to Theta star that's
a lot because Theta star is a universal
quantity right you you know what Theta
star is you know the City Star exists
even before you draw the samples
why because Theta star is the minimizer
of the population risk the population
risk doesn't depend on the samples it
only depends on the discussion so that's
why you can you can apply this with
theta equals to your stock so that's why
we got this inequality one because we
got L has a star minus L here star
it's less than
o tilde or foreign
so now the question is whether you can
apply this to
Theta hat
an answer is no you cannot apply it to
it and it's not only just because you
have some subtle kind of mathematical
rigorousness it's really just a it's not
even correct it's very far from correct
to apply to Theta hat it's not a small
kind of mathematical nuances kind of
thing and the reason is that there is a
there's a dependency issue right so like
as I alluded before a little bit so the
the dependency is that you have first
half see the star right so the star
depends on the the population
distribution
and Theta star is something you you that
is kind of exists there before you when
you draw the sample and then you draw
the sample
and then you get to say the hat and then
you come right and then you can um
compute for example I'll take a hat uh
or l h the Hat this kind of things but
had a heart depends on the samples so so
that means that L of x i y i
had a hat
are not independent with each other
so so you cannot apply half the
inequality because they are not
independent variables
so and this is kind of important because
you know if you can really apply this
actually
you always if if you can apply this uh
coffee the head you can always get one
more story then there's no dependency on
anything like uh the machine learning
would be much much easier like we don't
have to think about
sample complexity is always small
so
um
so so basically the next uh well two
weeks we are dealing with this you know
how do we deal with say that heart
right so um
so so the idea to fix this is called
uniform convergence
foreign
is that you want to apply this
apply whole thing
to any Theta
that is
predetermined before joining data
right you can you can apply this to any
say that it's predetermined before
joining the data
I guess this this might sound a little
bit kind of like um
um by yourself a little bit conflict so
what I really mean is that
you want to prove that
so what we have what we know now
is that for every data
probability
I'll higher Theta minus so for every
Theta that is has nothing to do with
those samples you know this is true
for someday for
of course I didn't specify exactly what
Epsilon Delta is but but this is the
form of the theorem we're approving
right now we can prove right now and we
have proved this for
um and you can plug in say that it's
equal to start that's fine but this is
not
uh the same as
four
this issue
so so the second statement is what we
I'm going to prove uh in the next Well
to Well two weeks but there's these two
are two different statements the second
statement is saying that
you first draw the samples and then
after you draw the samples for all Theta
with two functions these two functions
are closed maybe it's kind of useful to
draw a figure right so
um
so there is a function called
L Theta right
um and here this Dimensions Theta and
the Y Dimension is the L Theta and now
let's look at what's the empirical loss
so the empirical laws
um
so
I guess maybe let me give example where
these two statements are different
so let's think about there are only two
three cases
so
so this is a virtual example right so
consider the case versus I also Hearts
data
is
this function
so it's the right function with
probability one third
and it and it's the
orange function
with probability of one third
and maybe let's say is the
grief
this is a starting I guess that you have
different color
Korean function with probability 1 3.
and so what you know is that
for every Theta so if you forever so for
any fixed data if you look at the
probability that L height Theta
is different from L Theta let's say
you're just different
so what's the chance that they are
different
so this chance is something like
um
something like two-thirds
right because if you look at any
Point any Theta you know for some Theta
actually it's always the three function
is always the same right they're always
the same but maybe for example if you
pick a
pick a point here
right if you look at this point then
which probably is a third
I also have Theta is this right point
which is different from L Theta and with
this other two possibilities right it's
probably two-thirds uh IO has Theta is
equal to l Theta right so so basically
for every Theta
you have some
um sorry I should write this is equal to
this
a third right so so basically for
everything you have something like this
right like a
um
and on the other hand if you look at
some statement like this
right so
if you look at this for every Theta L
High Theta is close to L Theta
then what's what's this thing this is
saying that basically these two
functions are the same you know globally
and clearly in any of these red yellow
and green cases this probability is zero
because
um because in both of these three random
cases right so the two functions are not
always the same right there's always
some chance that there are there's some
diff there's some differences so so that
so that shows that you cannot uh easily
switch the probability with the for all
quantifier they are not just not
switchable
um
I guess you know probably you have seen
that also like uh
in Sometimes some of you probably would
expect this like this is about unionbank
right like when you do Union bonds
there's always these kind of things like
where you whether you can switch the
probability with four contract which we
are gonna talk about in a moment
um
so so basically
um this is probably I hope this is
demonstrating that it's kind of more
difficult to prove that uh on
to prove I will say the Hat minus
I'll have to to prove equality two
so
more the take-home point is that it's
more difficult
to prove
equality to two what's equal to two
equality towards the difference between
I also the Hat
and I'll have the hat and the reason is
that the hat is a function of the data
set and you lose the independence
and so the goal of the uh of the many of
the like the rest of the lectures is to
show that this is indeed bounded uh
using the so-called uniform convergence
and by uniform convergence let me just
summarize I hope you got some intuition
here already like we need to prove
something like
probability
that for all Theta has had
close to L Theta it's less than Epsilon
so we need to prove something like this
using some uh some techniques and and
you see that
you're gonna get much looser bounds when
you prove something like this the
Epsilon Delta would be different from
the Epsilon Delta that you can get when
the the for our quantifier is outside
the probability
so I guess I'll I'll show how to improve
this compound
um
in the in the next few lectures but just
the
um
just uh I guess uh
um so that this suffices you know I
guess as expected if I have a claim 2
so if you so you know that
I also don't have minus LS is a star
it's less than I guess
by claim one
this is less than the differences
between
I'll take the star minus L height Little
Star
plus Iota hat minus L height to the Hat
and this is less than two times the soup
over all Theta
foreign
right so if you can show that for all
Theta they are similar then uh you have
a Bound for the excess risk
so maybe just a in some sense
if you draw the picture here so
basically what you want to show is that
suppose this is the population risk L
Theta you want to show that with high
probability your your empirical risk is
something like this
um which is kind of like uniformly close
to the the population risk that's kind
of the intuition we have and and
actually
um let's see yeah so uh and actually you
know if you you know in the second half
of the lecture like after week five or
week six
we're also going to talk about that it's
not actually
this picture is actually not entirely
accurate in the sense that this this
picture is actually in the sense that
indeed the in many cases the empirical
risk is kind of like Bonnet you know
by some absolute right within the app
Zone uh within the the population risk
but also it doesn't look like this kind
of fluctuating so what really happens is
something like
maybe you have a function population
risk like this this is population
and the empirical risk is something
first of all close to the population
risk but also in terms of the shape and
the curvature is also closed so it
wouldn't be like that fluctuating it
would be something like maybe this
so so not only in terms of the value
they are closed but also in terms of
some other properties maybe the the
curvature the ship there are also
somewhat closed uh and and this is
useful for certain kind of like cases
when you especially care about
optimization right so for example
um
if the the importance is so fluctuating
then it becomes harder to optimize and
and we care about optimization sometimes
you want to show that
um the empirical risk
um can also have nice
properties for your computational
purposes
okay I guess that's uh that's a perfect
time uh stopping time
um okay thanks